SHAW TURNING, TAKING A BODY
CHECK RIGHT THERE AND STEERED
ASEID Y BTHNENA AND PSEE TDO
BURN, IT IS ANDREAS ATHANASIOU
AND LOOKING TO GO BACKHAND AND
WHAT A STOP BY PRIEC AND IT IS A
DETROIT TO THE SECOND PERIOD
WITH THE MAN ADVANTAGE AND IT IS
TATAR TO THE ICE, HABS KILLING
IT OFF AND NIELSEN FIRING IT.
AND CAREY PRICE WITH A PIECE.
AND WHEEL SEEN, THE FIRST BORN
D BRED PLAYER ROM ENMARK TO
NOW WITH I
STILL WAITING.
RASMUSSEN, A SHOT RIGHT NO.
EBRNDOU!
STILL LOOSE, OH, CAREY PRIC!E
DANAULT HERE OVER TO THE
HELPSIDE AND THIS IS
de la RE OSOWN ITWH TI.
de RlaEOS, ABDELKADER!
HE HITS ANYTHING THAT IS MOVING
IN RED.
BENN HAS TO BE CAREFUL AND NOW
BERTUZZI, WITH ROOM.
IN ON PRICE, TO THE BACKHAND,
REBOUND, STILL LOOSE IN THE
CREASE NAD FOLLOWING UP, PRCIE
KEEPS IT OUT!
UNBELIEVABLE!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
THREETO  HLPE.
GALLAGHER FOR KULAK.
KUAKL IWTH A GOAL IN THIS HOCKEY
GAME.
GLENDENING, CHIPPING IT OUT.
HELM, A DISH AND PRIC OENCE
WITKOWSKI, NOW BACK.
FIVE SECONDS REMAINING,
WITKOWSKI HAVING A LOOK.
AND THAT WILL DO IT.
[ Applause ]
[ Horn ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Bryan: CAREY PRICE, WIN
NUMBER 315.
HETAN ALONE IN MONTREAL
CANADIENS HISTORY.
[ Horn ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Applause ]
>> Mike:ND AT WAS INEITAB,
HE W GNGTO   IT.
BUT IT DOES NOT DIMINISH THE